you know it's one of the inspirations
for me going into science so you sort of
have to go while this actually happened
I'm Sarah Russell and I'm research
scientist at the Natural History Museum
looking at the formation and evolution
of the solar system and the evolution of
the moon my name is Marisa lo and I'm a
PhD student at the University of
Manchester and I look I'm Wally funk and
I'm part of the mercury 13 testes from
back in the 60s I was being processed
you see how girls could pass to be into
space NASA said you're doing great
you've passed all the tests but we can't
take you because you don't have an
engineering degree for the Apollo 11
landing I was 2 years old so I'm not
sure that I remember it I do remember
seeing the liftoff and the going around
in the ER and the atmosphere and the
landing that was thick it was fantastic
so when the moon landings took place I
wasn't born we're gonna have a look at a
film of the highlights of the Apollo 11
landing when you're coming down for a
landing
right it's just like when I'm coming in
you can see anything
this is really interesting I was
describing what the surface is like here
so this would have been the first time
that someone had seen what the lunar
regolith is like so the lunar regolith
is like the soil that's on top of the
surface of the moon and it actually
turned out to be super powdery and
actually the powder got everywhere but
all of their suits
I know when they left the flag actually
fell down they're just experimenting of
different ways to walk around the moon I
know they tried to experimented with
jumping around and walking around okay
so they're collecting a core tube sample
so we do this for a lot of rocks and
actually glaciers on earth as say ice or
rocks are deposited were formed over
time that's recording a history as
you're going deeper into the ground so
these cores are giving us more
information than we could just get at
the surface and we're still studying
these rocks are now 15 years later we're
still working on them there I guess
lifting off yep
amazing Wow thank you that's really good
energy feels really emotional because I
actually I'm not sure that I have seen
that I haven't seen that for decades to
be honest I can't imagine what it must
have been like to watch this life what I
remember really struck me was the adults
all seemed so excited about it I
honestly didn't know that adults were
capable of having that emotion how new
was the kind of light they had to do for
this then compared to you know the
conventional tradition there's no
comparison they were going into space by
Vi rocketry they were just kind of ahead
of their time but they were doing what
they needed to do to get into space and
to get to the moon when Kennedy said in
61 we're going to get a man on the moon
by the end of the decade that must have
seemed unbelievable you get kind of
overwhelmed by what an amazing
achievement it was I knew all the tests
that those guys had to go through
because I beat them on many many of the
tests the physical and the mental test
even nowadays we're still thinking of
ways of landing on the moon and it's not
it's not a given and the success rate of
moon landings isn't 100 percent you
can't jump from there to the Apollo you
have to learn to fly you have to learn
fly jets and you have to understand how
the gravity works so you just don't jump
in there and go up there it's really
hard to say what I feel would be like
without moon landings but my I'm not
sure that we would even have a field
without the moon landings during each of
the Apollo missions they placed several
seismometers around the landing site
using these seismometers they've been
able to deduce the internal structure of
the moon and before the Apollo missions
this is something we didn't have a grasp
on at all before Apollo we had no idea
how the moon got there we didn't know
how it formed this giant impact of a
mars-sized body into the earth smashed
into it and then splash material out
that coalesced to form the moon
I think it's that's that's amazing
scientific achievement of Apollo I was
speaking to someone who works at the
Goddard Space Flight Center a couple of
weeks ago and they were saying that
they're using an Apollo 16 core that's
never been opened before it was closed
on the moon this sample
now it's gonna be opened by her lots of
countries are interested in go back to
moon which is great because there's
still so much that we don't know about
the moon so the Apollo missions only
looked at a tiny bit of the moon they
looked at the near side and the equator
we've only scratched the surface it's
wonderful what they're all doing and
what they plan to do it many books I
have signed where do you want your kids
to go well they wanted to be astronaut
getting to watch a live moon landing
would be amazing I don't know what I'd
be doing if it wasn't for Apollo but I'm
not don't know that I'd be a research
scientist